traditional public schools knock it out
of the park in many places my guess is
they'll continue to thrive the ones that
are good and when you give parents
choices all schools get better they
don't get worse they get better governor
Bush thanks for joining us here at a
yeah you bet net so I want to sort of
get to school choice in a minute which
is sort of my bailiwick but I'm curious
to get into a little your deep
background as governor when you were
governor you did have big pushes on
school choice but you also had the eight
plus plan which had a lot of the
hallmarks of what we think of as
accountability today but back before it
was cool so can you just give me a
thumbnail on that and what do you think
were some of the biggest successes from
that well this will sound like a bygone
era
but when I ran for governor I laid out
what I wanted to do in education I
actually laid out the A+ plan in detail
it became the prominent dominant issue
of the campaign right my my opponent
attacked me for it I defended it I won
and it gave me a mandate to do it which
is a lesson that I think policymakers
and elected officials should remind
themselves of from time to time and you
were able to do it fairly quickly right
first year most of it so I went to visit
250 schools kind of dehorn myself
because I've always believed in vouchers
which at the time was you know very
dangerous apparently so the a-plus plan
was we would grade schools based on
student learning
a B C D and F and if the school was an F
they would be given a voucher if they
were have two years out of out of four
and if if they showed improvement they
would get a hundred dollars per student
directly to the school no cut from the
for the state or the of the school
district we we eliminate social
promotion and the next year we created
the Opportunity Scholarship Program the
corporate tax scholarship program and
the Mackay scholarship program which
were the first statewide voucher
programs kind of all within a two and
three year period and it was a big damn
deal
it was tumultuous to say the least and
the lessons learned were that you've got
a a fun you're
priorities first you can't you can't
have provocative policy without backing
it up with money to you've got to not
just create the in terms of
accountability you can't just say here
are our expectations now go do it you
got to help people that have never
actually been held to account and so we
we focused on struggling schools and
providing resources and the the system
adapted to this in a dramatic way one of
my key questions is you put in a
particular pretty toothsome requirement
that if third graders couldn't pass
their reading benchmarks they weren't
going to fourth grade and I'm curious
about how that works in large part
because I see in a number of places we
have really lofty ambitions and instead
of seeing sort of to some requirements
oftentimes we see people patting their
numbers to get yeah sort of the numbers
are Mack truck wide yeah exactly
so how'd that go that's the first
question how'd that go it sounds like it
means we went from 32% of students being
level one which I would call
functionally illiterate
below basic readers to 14% in a two year
period but we had 14 percent of our kids
held back yeah in this in the second
year which is you know it's a pretty
provocative idea right but the net
result was that so we created this this
gate and said we're not kidding we're
not gonna have big Mack truck wide
exemptions but we did summer school
again
we put reading coaches in every school
to teach teachers how to teach reading
we gave reading certificates to teachers
to get an additional pay we implemented
early childhood education all of which
you know together created improved
literacy and lower a number of
functionally illiterate kids it was it
was in my reelection effort where had we
not made those those appreciable gains
that I described had we maintained the
status quo had nothing changed it would
have been you know 25% or 30% of all
third graders stuck in third grade that
would have been really ugly so I you
know since then there's been a lot of
water under the bridge right we've had
no child left behind we've had the Obama
era waivers race to the top now we're at
s and we've had common core there's so
many things knowing what you know now
and have learned about these lessons
what do you wish that you had known back
when you passed a plus that you didn't
know them you know the the a-plus plan
worked in reality there were there were
imperfections for sure but it worked so
one of the things that was so helpful
was that we built a data base in our
state researchers use it all the time to
kind of study education outcomes on a
longitudinal basis we were blessed with
a data bank that allowed us to adjust
and kind of anticipate where we would go
so cut scores kind of turned out to be
important in accountability yeah they do
huh
yeah a really important and if you can
kind of anticipate where you go so that
you you don't have a you have a bell
curve instead of a everybody's in a or
everybody's in a half that's important
and we had good data to be able to move
us towards you know rising student
achievement along the way there were
there was a lot of wavering not so much
in my administration but after there's
you know there's always a reason not to
move it up a notch right and and then
you're then you're you know we've
basically I think as a nation we had
some significant gains not because of me
but during my time as governor many
states had gains now we've seen a kind
of a flatlining because there's a
there's a push against accountability
principally because testing is you know
bad I guess from the minds of people and
the reason is that we over test we
there's all sorts of tests at local
school districts require that our part
of the statewide accountability system
in these states and it's almost low so
it's designed to like end up really
hurting accountability so our foundation
advocates fewer tests more relevant
tests and more information from those
tests to turn it into a diagnostic tool
that's interesting let me ask you this
sort of juxtaposition between as a
bridge to the talk
choice programs as a lot of public
school accountability would could be
seen as increasing regulation on public
schools and then on the other hand we
have private school choice proposals and
a lot of the times we say you know we
need a light regulatory touch here how
can you explain to people why you can
hold both those things in your hands and
say I don't think accountability is
regulation regulation is the number of
you know cafeteria workers you have to
have per X number of students or
imposing another mandate on top of
schools because there was an isolated
tragic case of whatever that's that's
the state mandates that that local
school districts are very right to
complain about accountability is
actually liberating people you know we
tried to create an environment look we
just we want rising student achievement
and here's how we're gonna measure it
you go out and do your work and we'll
fund it and we'll you know we'll help
you so I would distinguish between
traditional education regulation and
accountability now the private there
there is a friction in school choice
programs the private programs because
you don't want to impose rules on top of
private schools to make them basically
look like traditional public schools and
we've always struggled what do you test
if someone takes public money do you
disclose it when there's only ten kids
you know there's there's a lot of
details in this and nuance that gets
worked out different ways by States but
the basic premise is that you're
transposing this top-down bureaucracy
and in rulemaking process that's been
around for a hundred years in the
traditional public schools to parents to
make this decision for themselves as
long as you give them the right
information and they know how their kid
is doing I think that that's appropriate
right so you're for you support a number
of private school choice programs all of
them and and you support charters as
well I have a lot of folks who who
really like charter schools and they say
you know what charters are enough
charters are enough we don't need these
private school choice programs what
would you say to them why would you say
we do do need private I've met a lot of
people that are
you know love high-performing charter
schools in the inner city and there's
some phenomenal schools that just really
hit it out of the park now but it's not
a zero-sum game advocating support of
archdiocese schools in New York City
does not hurt Success Academy yeah I
don't it's it's just it's truly not a
question of one or the other
in fact they they live side-by-side and
if they're both flourishing all the
better so we just had this event
upstairs talking about education savings
accounts which I've spent a great deal
of time studying I want to ask you a
couple of questions about those but for
the viewers that may not know what they
are can you just kind of describe what
they vary but they're basically accounts
that parents receive they receive a
literally on account of money depending
on what's appropriated to be able to
choose going to a private school or to
break it up just aggregate it as you
said upstairs big word yeah - we like
big word think that hey yeah hey yeah I
know
tutoring you know - after-school
programs all sorts of other uses in
Florida the the principal is a program
that is really successful is the Gardner
scholarship program named after the
former president of the state state
Senate who was the sponsor of the bill
and now 10,000 parents or students their
parents get to choose from and they get
I think up to $10,000 so it's a robust
amount of money and it can be to keep
your child in the school a traditional
public school but get additional
services there are those services by the
way under the federal law should be
provided but as you might know the
federal law isn't always implemented in
a faithful way and a lot of parents are
very frustrated that the public schools
don't their individual education plan
that the law requires be met isn't being
met so this is a way for them to take
that power and implement it on their own
sure and ESA is our education savings
accounts essays are sort of the new kid
on the block as far as it comes to
choice programs we have tax credit
scholarships and so only have we have
voucher traditional voucher Pro
grams what is it that they bring that is
just totally different than these other
forms the main difference is that you're
empowering the money goes to parents to
choose how they how they spend it on
behalf of their children there's you
know there's restrictions of course but
it's it's different than then a kind of
a binary choice of going to the
traditional school that your kid was
already going to or at private option
yes A's give you the choice of going to
a private school staying in a public
school and using private services along
the way so it's it's a it's a much more
dynamic flexible tool for parents to
help their children learn yeah that's
interesting it raises the question of
the supply side we can do a lot about
the demand side by giving families money
and ways to use it that they they
otherwise wouldn't but it's sort of
harder to develop a supply side of
providers who are going to kind of meet
those demands if you just have school
choice well it's obvious that schools
rise up with the SAS you need all kinds
of different providers what have you
seen in Florida and in other states in
your work with the foundation for
excellence in education that that give
you the confidence that the supply side
will respond well supplies or supply
side always responds to demand I mean
it's kind of helped free-market
economics work unfortunately this is not
a free market in the sense that if
there's you know capital costs really a
principal cost for developing private
alternatives and there you have to be
creative and so if you know you got a
you got to raise capital you have to
identify buildings and provide support
for that it's a challenge but ultimately
what we found was that as our corporate
tax scholarship program Mackay
scholarship program gardener scholarship
program went from literally zero to now
one hundred and fifty thousand students
that new schools were formed and and
supply ultimately met the met the need
and they're still big waiting lists of
kids that are trying to get into these
programs right now a lot of these
programs are going to be state programs
but they're going to run into
school finance structure which is we
have local dollars I've got some dollars
from my state and across the nation
there's about 10% federal funding 45%
state 45% local right well if you're a
state making rules with 45 percent of
your money to try and provide real
education real educational opportunities
for kids you're stuck in a pretty good
Jam if you can't come up with the funds
to give people a valuable voucher or
guess a can you just speak to that
challenge sure so in in the case of our
programs the the principal the largest
voucher program is the corporate tax
scholarship program and it's less per
student than the traditional public
school option so in effect every child
that leaves the public school to go to
the private school is saving the state
money and there's a growing
understanding of that which sustains
these programs so on the one hand your
and and in Florida we have a emerging of
our local and state funding which is
makes this much easier to us so in the
states that don't have that you're
you're gonna have to appropriate money
the Gardner program is separate line
item in appropriation right which gets
to the basic point if it's a high
priority it ought to be first funded
right you know Washington didn't work
this way but most states if a governor
says this is my number one priority
you take the first money to fund your
first priorities and so we never we
weren't constrained other states you
know where it's where it's a big fight
in the legislature really are hampered
by this for sure
well can you I'm gonna ask you a
question from your perspective as head
of foundation for excellence in
education so can you just tell our
viewers what is the foundation and
what's its mission sure it's a it was
formed in 2007 it started as a place
where we could tell the Florida story
which is really a story of choice
accountability and a focus on early
childhood literacy and and the
combination of all this yielding rising
student achievement which is ultimately
what matters so but we've morphed into
still telling that story and
we go state-by-state to policymakers -
in the legislature and in the executive
branch kind of forewarning them of the
mistakes that we might have made which
is always helpful yeah not to remake the
mistakes that others have made and
encouraging them to be big and bold and
providing support when they do and then
helping them and guide them on
implementation this is complex stuff
yeah so whether it's testing or just
basically the the science of reading or
making sure that accountability system
is done the right way where it's not
going to blow up in your face the next
year we've had states that have ignored
our advice in that regard and it blew up
and then you know the next year and they
had to start over it's a we want to be a
trusted adviser we don't BigDog it you
know show up at a place and take credit
we operate with typically with business
with chambers and with local and state
based policy institutes to do this in
partnership always being deferential to
the leaders that take the you know to
have to do the courageous thing which is
to advocate whether you're a governor
remember the legislature so taking
Florida off the table for obvious
reasons what other state is just
knocking out of the park in terms of
education generally but private school
choice programs charters who do you
think's really doing great I'd say
Arizona has a robust charter school
program in a burgeoning private school
program governor Ducey is a big and bold
leader Brian sand of all did something
extraordinary but you know the
legislature changed and and I don't
think he got it off the ground to make
it completely sustainable because
there's not enough scale yet but he had
a full-throated ESA wow I mean that
that's about the ultimate thing so huge
credit for making that big first step
Indiana has it's kind of followed the
footsteps of Florida and done some
things even bigger so Louisiana although
you know there there's every state kind
of ebbs and flows Tennessee has had big
learning gains with a focus on teacher
preparation and and public school choice
so there's there's some good states
there Colorado is a place where actually
bipartisan consensus has emerged from
time to time as one of the few states we
have not a but it still exists yeah well
apparently in Colorado's the water up
there or the maybe that new initiative
that's a donation it's uh every States
different and you know Mississippi is a
place where starting really from nothing
right governor Bryant's done a really
good job of they have they've passed or
they're passing an ESA there's big big
support in the business community and in
the political leadership for meaningful
efforts there and they're focused on
reading and they didn't have a charter
school program yeah until recently so
depending on where you are on the
spectrum of change you know these are
big steps right and we help each state
kind of uniquely based on where they are
so you you support vouchers you support
online education you support ESA charter
schools and these are all worthy of
support but they all do inevitably leave
students away from traditional school
districts and neighborhood schools right
a lot of people will say well you know
that's because you hate neighborhood
districts and traditional public schools
if that's not the case you know as these
things grow and they succeed what do you
see is the future for traditional school
districts and neighborhood school
well neighborhood schools particularly I
think are going away because they they
have broad support among moms and dads
just because of the convenience and the
safety factor parents have it to have
lots of reasons why they support their
children going to particular schools
it's not always the way the bean
counters and the bureaucrats suggest and
so traditional public schools will
always be well funded will there be a
little bit of you know stress because
the long term pension obligations the
sins of the past put pressure on on
school district yeah but so what you
know I mean if you go to some states
more money's being spent to deal with
the pension obligations decided 20 years
ago classroom education has languished
even though they spend double what state
like Florida yes is that fair the fact
that we were more to
Lynden in how we went about it should we
boom own the fact that states are gonna
have to make some adjustments no I mean
that's part of what what I think is an
important element of a 21st century
education system to move away from this
industrial model that has failed in the
private sector and would have failed
already in the public sector had it not
been for all of us paying our taxes to
sustain something that's not as
efficient as it needs to be but
traditional public schools knock it out
of the park in many places and my guess
is they'll continue to thrive the ones
that are good and when you give parents
choices all schools get better they
don't get worse they get better
so there's a number of private school or
just choice options right there's public
school choice and charters we have ES
A's tax credit scholarships vouchers and
a number of different kinds of programs
so let me present you with a false
forced choice if you had to choose one
to to bet on what's what's your favorite
program Thanks
I mean if you created a statewide ESA
program and you created a repository of
options for for parents and there was
some degree of transparency about their
effectiveness and what the price was and
all the things that a consumer of
something of that importance would need
and you had accountability around it
which would be different than the
traditional accountability so that
parents would know what was working and
what wasn't that to me would be the
ideal situation I mean if a girl could
dream it would be to turn parents
well-informed parents with accurate
transparent information into the school
districts yeah it's a little bit of a
chicken and egg thing of course you
can't have a vibrant marketplace of
educational service providers without
developing an information system that
gives feedback to consumers and of
course you can't get that system up
until you have the vibrant system but
what do you think states should think
about as they're trying to develop that
and try to to just grease those gears I
think that's what they need to think
about is pass a if you pass a voucher
bill or you know expanded charter any
any expansion of
parental the parents are ultimately
accountable for their children's
education
you've got to along the way at the same
time simultaneously give them a system
of real information you know as I
mentioned upstairs that's a place where
generally the governments have failed
no they just don't think that way there
are insular in their nature that they've
never had to market you know they've
never had to actually learn how to
present something in a way that a mom
and a dad would would understand how
they're how they're doing in fact they
in some cases they don't want you to
know because you know if kids aren't
learning it's not like a great great
conversation that's true keep it quiet
indeed well that's how do you get to a
place where you know you have someone
graduating with a high school diploma
with an eighth grade level reading
capability how do you get to the point
where a significant percentage 40 50
percent of kids aren't college and/or
career ready more than that actually
have to retake if they go to college
they have to retake high school reading
a high school math the only way you do
it is that you've kept it quiet now cuz
no mom would say well that's great
yeah little Johnny my little Johnny went
12 years and is a ninth grade reader
woohoo yeah not a lot to cheer about let
me let me ask you about advice for
legislators or governor's that are
trying to develop an ESA in their state
now of course these are gonna go through
the the push and pull of of making
legislation the sausage-making
and they have to compromise sometimes on
price sometimes on how many people are
eligible sometimes on what kind of
regulation they're gonna cover where
would you say if you're developing an
ESA bill you can't compromise on where
can they not afford to compromise on it
I think it's it's making sure that
there's going to be private providers
opting in which means price if it's if
you it would be better to cap the number
and go back to fight again the next
session of raising the cap but making
sure that this this amount of money
while lower than the per student public
school it always should be lower than
that right but it's it's enough to be
able to attract high quality providers
into the arena and so why would you say
it shouldn't always be lower quality I
just not lower quality a lower amount of
money
then what is spent in the local public
schools I just was any transformation
you know in in in life outside of
government innovation normally cost less
and yields a better result and we should
apply that model I think rather than the
you know the tired old model it cost
more money i more money isn't the
leading indicator of of a better result
and plus politically if you're gonna go
propose I got this great idea I'm gonna
propose a voucher that has double the
cost or 50% more twenty-five percent
more than the per student funding by the
way because it's private we're not going
to impose all these rules on top of them
so you know we don't know exactly if
it's going to be perfect that's not
you're not gonna get that passed any
state legislature a number of people
that I know are familiar with they will
criticize private school choice programs
on equity grounds they will say well you
know this is the people who are gonna
take advantage of this or
disproportionately white or rich or
something else private the private the
school choice yes and so how do you
respond when arguments like that it's
just not true it's not true at all every
data point suggests otherwise most of
these programs are taken advantage of by
lower-income people the programs for
children with learning disabilities are
pretty you know across the special both
higher income and lower income but
there's no disproportionate that I'm
aware of
whether it's charter schools or or
private voucher programs the exact
opposites true that people because of
how the programs are typically crafted
people lower income benefit from these
programs the issue that I think is
important is to make sure that parents
that are you know a single mom that's
struggling with two jobs and as sees
this as a chance of for their child to
rise up and and to be successful to go
to a private school that they're
informed they get the proper information
you know that to me is a bigger issue if
you're in a more affluent area and you
have the information available and you
can seek it out and you you know you
have a network of
community that can just kind of by the
tom-toms tell you right what teachers
good what schools good if you don't have
all that then I think it's the
obligation of the the state to provide
that information to level out the
playing field right so private school
choice has a friend in the White House
and at the Department of Education that
they never really had you know charters
have had support from the administration
before but but not private school choice
but private school choice has grown in
state capital after state capital has
not been Washington DC that's been
pushing it so do you think that this new
support from the administration is going
to be a change in that and what my how
might states you know make good on that
that new support in DC well it could be
that there's a there'd be a federal
voucher program emerge in the welfare
reform or the fight against poverty that
emerges in in Paul Ryan's world next you
know this year I don't know that would
be wonderful to include it because
empowering parents that are near at the
poverty level with with the you know
with more choices in education would be
a key element of that I'm a little wary
of it only in that it should not hurt
the existing choice programs that exist
across the country it should enhance
them there should be enough flexibility
that if the federal government wants to
provide support which states that
already have these voucher programs and
school choice programs would love to
have it shouldn't be with so many
strings attached that it stifles the
work that's already being being done so
my guess is that we'll continue on this
path that this is really a state issue
locally administered the federal
government has with Betsy DeVos
certainly as a strong advocate of
accelerate school choice programs across
the country and hopefully she could be a
partner but I cannot imagine a time when
the Trump administration with secretary
to Ross's input at least would would
make it harder for the existing choice
programs to prevail Jeb Bush thanks for
coming to AEI and talk to us you bet
Thanks
hey everyone that's the end of our
discussion with Governor Jeb Bush thanks
for watching as always let us know what
other topics you'd like AI scholars to
cover on viewpoint and to learn more
about education savings accounts check
the links in the description below
[Music]